happy winter everybody well not quite
yet
almost we're almost into winter we've
got a lot of clouds out there beautiful
early morning color let's get into your
forecast and find out about those
chances for rain for santa
the clouds all coming up from the south
so everything is pretty mild this
morning i mean considering normal highs
should be in the upper normal morning
low should be in the upper 30s and we're
in the mid 40s generally around the
valley 6 48 the sunrise 4 30 the sunset
the shortest day of the year we've got
almost 14 and a half hours of daylight
night and a her night time and nine and
a half hours of daylight so there's not
much daylight to work with so we want to
warm up as much as we can clouds keeping
everything much milder we're almost 10
degrees more warmer this morning than we
were yesterday
we're down in the 30s we were close to
freezing 37 at red rock laughlin's got
some wind prompts in the 30s mesquite's
in the 30s so those are a little bit
cooler spots clouds to start winter
officially the winter solstice 7 59 a.m
shortest day of the year because the sun
actually leans we lean away from the
north pole so we lean away from the sun
and that makes it the shortest day for
us chance of showers before christmas
eve and then a chance of rain really
through christmas weekend so we have a
lot of opportunity to get some rain and
a lot of good chances for mountain snow
we also are looking at some pretty good
rain and thunderstorms across the
southeast especially for florida they've
got the best chances for thunderstorms
with rain in atlanta the rain sliding
north up into the carolinas out to the
west this is a huge train of moisture
it's coming from the subtropics and way
down out around hawaii this is the core
low up here you can see it right off the
coast of northern california and oregon
it continues to spin it's pushing some
showers into the coast and there are
winter storm warnings for the sierra
nothing for us has been issued yet so
we'll get through a couple of days of
clouds again
these should thin out a little bit
through the afternoon so we should see a
little more sunshine for the afternoon
and temperatures are going to be a
little milder because this is milder air
coming up from the south instead of from
the northwest which would be much colder
we're looking for 59 by the afternoon
some southwest breezes not much but
let's get down to the
real deal let's get down to santa claus
shall we all right so christmas eve
upper 50s a chance of rain through the
day it's not a huge chance like 30
for the afternoon but we'll keep just a
slight chance of showers for santa all
the way up until midnight and then again
on
christmas day but the best chance comes
before christmas eve that's thursday and
windy we're talking 30 plus mile an hour
winds on thursday so get your to do
stuff done now if you can and then
through the weekend those chances for
rain mountain snow snow levels are going
to be higher because of the warmer air
and we'll keep a slight chance of
showers into sunday and monday a little
cooler next week